You can spend your whole life imagining ghosts, worrying about the pathway to the future...
...but all there will ever be is what's happening here...
...and the decisions we make in this moment which are based in either love or fear.
So many of us choose our path out of fear disguised as practicality.
What we really want seems impossibly out of reach and ridiculous to expect...
...so we never dare to ask the universe for it.
I'm saying I'm the proof that you can ask the universe for it.
And if it doesn't happen for you right away,...
...it's only because the universe is so busy fulfilling my order.
Party size!
My father could have been a great comedian...
...but he didn't believe that that was possible for him.
And so, he made a conservative choice.
Instead, he got a safe job as an accountant.
And when I was 12 years old, he was let go from that safe job...
...and our family had to do whatever we could do to survive.
I learned many great lessons from my father,...
...not the least of which was that you can fail at what you don't want.
So, you might as well take a chance on doing what you love.